>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Marcia Davis: Danielle Allen
is a Harvard James Bryant Conant
University Professor at
Harvard and the Director
of the Edmond J. Safra
Center on Ethics.
She's a brilliant and
prolific political theorist,
known for her work on justice and
citizenship and her wingspan extends
from ancient Athens
to today's America.
She is the author of many
books, which would take too long
to mention here, but one
of her most well-known
and award-winning is
Our Declaration,
A Reading of the Declaration of
Independence in Defense of Equality.
And her latest, Cuz, The
Life and Times of Michael A.,
is the story of her first
cousin, Michael Alexander Allen.
Bright and promising,
Michael was arrested at 15
for an attempted carjacking
and was sentenced
as an adult to 13 years in prison.
He served 11 and essentially
grew up behind bars.
By 29 he was dead, a murder victim.
Michael Allen fought for his
humanity in the face of unforgiving
and ravenous social
economic circumstances,
including the criminal justice
system that sends children to jail,
disproportionately black
and brown children.
Michael had become, as Dr. Allen
writes, one of the millions gone.
This is a story about family.
It's a story about the Allen's, but
I would argue that it is a story
about our national family and what
can happen and what does continue
to happen to so many
of our children.
Now I think Dr. Allen is
particularly special and part
of a great tradition of those
who ask what kind of
people we want to be.
And in the 21st Century she
is definitely asking all
of us what kind of democracy
we want to make sure evolves.
Hers is a critical
voice and I think,
like founding father John Adams
and scholars like W.E.B. Du Bois,
she's using her intellect
in the service of us all.
Like James Baldwin she is a
witness and I think in the spirit
of the great Toni Morrison
she is using her career
to write a long love letter to our
humanity and to this democracy.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Danielle Allen.
[ Applause ]
She'll also be signing books from
11 to noon in the Expo Line 17.
She is a special sister.
Thank you.
>> Danielle Allen: I don't usually
start crying right at the beginning.
That was an extraordinary
introduction and I am so grateful.
[ Applause ]
>> Marcia Davis: An
extraordinary scholar.
>> Danielle Allen: It's also
just, I mean at so many levels
that was special and generous,
but it's not every day even just
that you get introduced by
somebody who has read your book.
And that means a lot
because I really am here
to ask people to read this story.
The book comes out on Tuesday so
this is sort of the launch actually,
as you guys are the launch.
And so I think and because
actually you did such a great job
of already sharing some of the
story I think I'm just going
to read the first chapter to start
and then I'll talk about the book
and then I'll read
a few more pieces,
but just to give you guys a feeling
for it and you can see Michael.
Oh, he's not there anymore.
He was on the screen,
so I hope you got a --
there he is, there's my baby cousin.
So the book has three parts.
Part one is called
Release and Resurrection.
Part two is called Inferno.
And Part three is called
Unforgiving World.
So Part one, Release
and Resurrection.
Limits are what any of us
are inside of, Charles Olson,
Chapter one, Garden
Party, July 2009.
Danielle, phone call for you.
It's your dad.
I broke away from a conversation
with my husband's cousins,
from glancing distracted talk about
the kids who were playing yards away
in their floral sundresses under
a soft English garden party sun.
Rising from the picnic
table I took the cell phone
from my husband and
walked a few steps.
Hi, dad. And, yeah, it's Michael.
My father's voice, the
careful clipped speech
of a retired professor, came
from across the Atlantic,
from Maryland through the ether.
It sounded as if it were miles
beneath the seas, crackling, wispy,
as if through the first
ever transatlantic cables.
He's dead.
What? Dead.
They found him shot in a car.
I'm coming.
Michael, my cousin, my baby cuz.
Sometimes an English spring mornings
a gauzy haze clings to the air.
This, though, was July
and now afternoon.
That same sort of whiteness
suddenly seemed to wrap the sky
and the surrounding willows.
And I near collapsed,
staggered into my husband's arms
and said, Jim, we have to go.
What? Michael is dead.
What? Dead.
We have to go.
Straightaway go.
We had to go to South Central.
And so we left.
So the book starts there
at the end of a life
and the reason it starts there is
because the life was
full of mysteries.
So Michael died in 2009 and,
obviously, it was a huge impact
for our whole family and
it's taken me a long time
to understand what
happened to my baby cousin.
And so I have been wrestling for
a long time with three questions.
As Marcie said, Michael was
arrested in 1995 when he was 15
for an attempted carjacking in
Los Angeles, tried as an adult,
sentenced as an adult,
sentenced to 13 years, served 11.
When he got out in 2006
I was the cousin on duty,
that's a phrase I use for
it, helping with reentry.
So I had been with him through the
prison experience, working with him
on correspondence courses,
taking the calls, you know,
will you accept a collect call
from the California Department
of Corrections, that's
sort of the routine of it.
And at any rate so I was the one
who helped with school and job
and so forth, and we worked hard
on that, and then three years
after he was first
released he was killed
by the transgender lover he'd
fallen in love with in prison.
And so, obviously, it's a
big and complicated story.
And Michael, in addition,
was a very talented person.
He was a brilliant writer.
I'll read you a little bit
of his writing in a minute.
And so we always had hoped before
he died that he would be able
to tell his own story, that he would
be able to share his experience
as a young person trying to survive
in the hard context of Los Angeles.
And so I had always wanted to find a
way to let Michael's voice come out
and that's what this book is,
the center of the book
is this beautiful essay
about Dante's Inferno that
he wrote during his college
correspondence courses.
But as I was wrestling with this
I was invited by a colleague
at Harvard, Professor Harry
Lisgates, Jr., [Assumed Spelling]
to give a set of lectures,
the Du Bois lectures, right?
These are sort of longstanding
famous lectures named
after W.E.B. Du Bois.
The point of giving these lectures
is that you're supposed to try
to say something about contemporary
African-American experience.
And I'm a political
philosopher, okay,
a really abstract analytical person,
so I kept giving Skip these
abstract titles, like I'm going
to give you lectures on race
and equality in the 21st Century
or political equality in the
future of race relations,
and these kinds of titles.
And I also kept delaying
the dates of the lectures.
As I got closer to it, I don't think
I can do it, let's postpone them.
And so finally I reached a point
where I couldn't postpone
these lectures any longer
and I also just reached a point
where I realized I couldn't
honestly address the question
of African-American
experience in the 21st Century
without telling my cousin's story.
So that's what I've done.
And so the point of saying all of
that is the process of writing was
as wrestling towards trying
to tell my cousin's story
and that required me to
answer a set of why questions.
Why was he dead?
Why had he been in
prison for so long?
And, most importantly, why did
this beautiful energetic, bright,
talented 15-year-old kid with a
big extended family who loved him,
that had resources, end
up on a street corner holding a
gun trying to take somebody's car?
Why? So that's where the title
of the book comes from, Cuz,
because of this, because of that,
as well as of course meaning cousin.
And so the reason the book starts
with his death is because that's
where the mystery starts
in some sense.
I mean the whole life is a
mystery, but the unraveling of it,
you have to sort of work your
way back, why was he dead?
And then, okay, we know he was dead
because he person he fell in love
with in prison killed him.
All right, but then, okay, well,
why was he in a situation to fall
in love with somebody in prison?
Well, if you go to prison when
you're 15 and you're there
for 11 years you are going to fall
in love with somebody, you just are.
It's like no way to avoid that.
And so then what does that
mean when you come out?
Your choice is a future where
you repudiate your loves in order
to have a new life or
you keep your loves.
It's the only possible choice.
That is a very, very hard choice.
So, yes, Michael was responsible
for all of his choices,
but you dig into Michael's story and
you begin to understand the degree
of difficulty that
comes with some choices.
I don't know how many of you
watched the Olympics last year.
Anybody? You guys are book readers,
do you watch the Olympics, as well?
Okay, you never know if
those things go together.
But the gymnastics, Olympics was
obsessed with this Indian gymnast,
Deepa Cara Machar [Assumed
Spelling], something like that,
I can't exactly remember,
because she was going
to do this maneuver called the
Produnova [Assumed Spelling],
which is the highest
degree of difficulty
of any gymnastics maneuver.
And the concern was people who
do this have a very high rate of
or risk of breaking their neck
or spinal injuries and so forth.
She pulled it off, she did it.
So you can do things, absolutely,
you can overcome in the face
of great degrees of difficulty,
but nonetheless most people who try
that maneuver are going to break
their back and that's just a fact
about the degree of
difficulty involved.
And I think that's how we have to
think about the kinds of challenges
that face young people in difficult
circumstances in this country.
That we have incredibly disparate
sets of degrees of difficulty
with which young people
are confronted
and they have to try to overcome.
So I'll say a little bit
more about that in a minute.
But let me at this point just
give you a little bit more
about who Michael was, a little
bit more about who I was as a kid,
and then what this experience of
dealing with incarceration was like.
So, let's see, if I tell
you a bit about Michael,
jump into his childhood
which comes late in the book.
Let's see if I've got
my page numbers here.
All right.
So they lived, so Michael
was born in Los Angeles.
He was one of three kids.
His mother, Karen, had
left her partner in Florida
because he was abusive and taken
the three kids to California.
And she, herself, didn't
go to college,
but worked her way into nursing.
Steady, hard worker, never could
make the ends meet with three kids,
either the end of time or of money.
But, nonetheless, when
Michael was coming
up into kindergarten they
managed to land in Highland Park,
just outside of Pasadena, for
five years and that was sort
of the stable and best part
of their time together.
In Highland Park the rights of
passage proceeded according to plan.
Michael's beautiful
kindergarten teacher,
the one with the blonde
Afro, loved him.
He graduated in high style
in white cap and gown.
He had gymnastics lessons
and played Little League
and went to summer camp.
To raise the funds for camp he
sold peanuts, so successfully even
that he funded his brother and
sister's trips to camps, too.
The trio would go for
three-week stints in the summer,
then they would come home, their
mother would do their laundry,
and then she would
send them off again.
They always went together.
Michael also had a glorious bicycle,
a He-Man [Assumed Spelling]
bike that he loved.
And their house was
on top of a hill.
He would fly down it barefoot,
not yet able to brake,
ending up at least
once with a swollen eye
with the bike all bent out of shape.
Having terrified his
sisters, cousins,
mother, anyone who was around.
His sister, who was growing
into a large-bodied girl
and had already developed a
mothering instinct, would cry out,
Michael, why don't
you put no shoes on?
We visited them often at this house,
once a month from sixth
to eighth grade.
I would come by, so that
another aunt, Big Roz,
and her girlfriend
could relax my hair.
The only slightly unusual ritual
in Michael's life at
the time was Alatots.
Since he couldn't have
remembered his mother's drinking,
which was done by the time
he was one, his enrollment
in the program must
have seemed mysterious.
Karen's spirit lightens when
she talks about their time
in Highland Park and how
amusing it was to eavesdrop
on her kids Saturday
morning Alatot meetings.
The trio would gather
outside her bedroom door,
whispering like a cloud
of buzzing bees.
They were whispering
about their grievances,
which she presumed
were mainly about her.
They were a united front and
in a small house all four
of them had five years
they are glad to remember.
And then me -- thank you.
Where were you when you were 15?
Close your eyes and try to recall?
I lived in a bedroom
with a brass bed,
with a blue-and-white striped
Laura Ashley comforter.
There were matching
valances on my windows,
and I had a window rolled top
desk with a drawer that locked
and held my secrets, including
dirty letters that I couldn't
at the time translate from a
German boy who had been the object
of a minor summer music
camp romance.
I was awkward and insecure, confused
about how to find my place in life.
Often I was lonely.
All of this was true despite
the fact that I was hurtling
into my junior year of high school
as captain of my varsity track team.
I was younger than most of my
classmates in Claremont High School
and my friends all had
their driver's licenses
by the start of junior year.
I was not, however, allowed
to ride in their cars.
The only time I ever got
grounded in high school was
when my librarian mother caught me
sneaking a ride with a friend to get
to my French class
at the local college.
I grew up in a college town, a
faculty brat, a nerd you can tell,
where everyone knew my mom and dad.
My parents had made a critical
decision early in the lives
of my younger brother Mark
and me that regardless
of what career opportunities came
my father's way they wouldn't move
until we had graduated
from high school.
I grew up in one place
where everyone knew me.
I couldn't even get away with
sneaking to my college courses.
Which of us does not remember
what life was like at 15.
The torments of adolescence
leave indelible marks.
Eight years after I got
grounded for sneaking to class
in that friend's car my 15-year-old
cousin, Michael Alexander Allen,
who also didn't yet
have a driver's license,
was arrested for the first time
for an attempted carjacking.
A few months later, after he
turned 16, he sat in Torrance,
California in court, the
standard swinging gates,
just inside the doors of the
courtroom, hands cuffed there
and in an orange suit in
December 1995 and January 1996,
as a judge determined that he
would be charged as an adult.
So writing this story to answer
the why questions took working
with family members, interviews,
working through a mystery.
It took the state level
equivalent of Freedom
of Information Act
requests to California.
Like I could give you a long
story about why it took that.
It was very hard to get Michael's
records, the police reports,
judicial records and
things like that.
But so it was a matter of
piecing through a mystery,
but a part of the work of piecing
through the mystery was also
about breaking through shame.
These kinds of experiences,
these kinds of stories
bring shame with them.
And the result of their shame
nobody talks to each other.
So one of the most painful
things that I have to admit is
that it wasn't until I
started working on this book
that my family talked about
what happened to Michael.
Literally.
Not even his mother and siblings,
they had never talked about it.
And so two things came out
of that process of talking
about it together,
two powerful things.
One was that Michael in the
last, before he was arrested
when he was 15, so late 13,
early 14 he had started flirting
with gangs in Los Angeles.
Crips and Bloods, very unusual thing
to do, to be flirting with both.
This was because he'd come from
outside of LA, was moving back
into LA, he didn't belong anywhere.
He was trying to figure
out where he fit.
He had just -- the family had
been devastated by a bad marriage
that Karen made when Michael was
10, and he had moved five times
in five years, changing
school midyear and so forth.
And he came into LA disconnected,
isolated, leaving a community
in the early '90s when violent crime
in Los Angeles was at its peak,
gang activity was high,
and the criminal justice system
had become so incredibly punitive.
And at any rate nobody, we didn't
know that he was doing this.
His mother didn't know.
We didn't figure it out till now,
till I was working on
this book, all right?
This is what I mean
about shame and silence.
And what it turns out is
like everybody had a
little piece of the story.
Somebody knew that Michael had
been doing a little bit of this,
but they thought that's all it was
and so they never said anything.
And somebody else had another
little bit, a piece of the story
and so they never said anything.
So one of the key lessons for me in
this whole experience has just been
about the importance of bringing
these stories to the surface
and the importance especially
for young people ages 10 to 14,
of the adults in their lives,
like break through the shame,
break through the trouble,
break through the competition,
break through the envy.
You've got to talk to each
other and it's the only way
to shepherd young people through
an incredibly difficult time.
Difficult for any adolescent.
I desired mobility in the same
way that Michael desired mobility.
I was lucky, my desire for
mobility led me to do things,
break rules in a really
safe, low risk environment.
The same desire inspired Michael.
There's not that much
difference in desire that we had,
but the conditions in
which we were acting
on our desires were
incredibly different.
And the adults around Michael,
we all have to take
responsibility for that.
By the same token the nature of the
environment which he found himself
in in Los Angeles was a product of
the war on drugs and the decision
by this country to take
a very common practice,
for example of marijuana
use, and to make it illegal
and to put a huge just burden
of secrecy on that world.
And there's a lot more
to be said about that,
about the way in which the war on
drugs has made it harder to parent
through adolescence, has also
taken people to prison unjustly,
and more significantly though has
built-up a black market economy
that constitutes in some sense
a parastate that runs parallel
to the legal state, with incredibly
powerful mechanisms of sanction,
itself, that counteract
the mechanisms
of sanction in the legitimate state.
And there's a war going on
between these two states
in which young people are caught
over and over and over again.
So the story that I am
trying to tell is really one
about how we think
about young people,
how we think about the
opportunities we present to them,
how we protect them, how we make
the world safe for them and ensure
that their potential
can be developed.
So let me, I know I'm running out
of time, so I want to go ahead
and just give you some
of Michael's voice
and then one little
bit more of my voice.
And I hope I've given you a rough
picture of what's in this book.
It's a little hard to describe it.
I'm used to writing books that
are straightforward arguments,
and I can just say point
one, point two, point three.
So this is a little different.
Okay, let's see.
So I'm just going to read
you the very last paragraph
of Michael's essay on the Inferno.
The title of his essay is,
the final title was Two Hells,
In Survival, Finding One's Self.
The handwritten copy of the essay
that he sent me had the change
of the title, he had first written
In Suffering Finding One's Self,
and then he crossed out
Suffering and changed it
to Survival, Finding One's Self.
The last paragraph.
And like Dante I am forced
to descend lower into hell
to achieve a full awakening.
I am forced into depression,
scarred by obscenities.
War after war, but each war
that I survive I'm a step closer
to a full awakening of self.
My hell is no longer
demonstrating what I am capable
of doing in order to survive.
It has become what I can tolerate
and withstand in order to live.
I cannot help but to
judge those around me.
I am one of them, but we
are far from the same.
Like Dante I am cursed with
the spirit of discernment,
which allows us to see
the truth for what it is.
There are those whom I despise
who are truly sick beyond healing
and they should never
leave this place.
Then there are those who await
to fulfill their destiny.
I see them as sincere and apologetic
heart for their illness deeds.
They are the ones who will
change the world positively
or positively change
someone's world.
Hell cannot hold the
latter of the two opposites,
but in time will only spit them back
out into society to
do what is right.
The hell that I live
in cannot hold Dante.
It'll contest and try one's self,
but it cannot hold Dante
and it will not hold me.
And the inferno, the
dead are trapped forever.
Surely the biggest and most
important difference in the inferno
and my hell called prison
is that I have a way out.
So that's Michael.
And then a little teeny bit more
about me, and this bit I'm going
to read about myself again
is you try to make the point
about how hard it is to
get these stories out.
When I ended up giving
these lectures,
did give his lectures
originally, I was astonished
by how many people came up to me
afterwards and said, you know,
I have a family member in prison,
too, and I've never told anybody.
And this wasn't just black people,
it was white people, as well.
And when you stop and think about
it it's not surprising, right?
Two million people are in
prison in this country.
So like presuming each of them is
connected to somewhere between 10
and 40 other people we're talking
like 20 to 80 million people
who are currently being affected
by incarceration in this country.
We have 5% of the world's
population,
but 25% of its incarcerated
population.
The world has never seen a penal
system like this, ever, ever.
I'm a classicist, this is antiquity.
Like I think of the whole span of
human time, nothing has been built
like this, ever, and we've
built it, we've done it.
I just believe we have to get
the stories to the surface.
So this, I'm just going
to read two sections
of chapters called Visiting 1.0
and Visiting 2.0 and
I'll just read them.
So, let's see.
As Michael, known to the
system as K10033, wrote --
inmates went by numbers, not names,
and visiting days were
allocated to sets of numbers.
Half of the evens on one Saturday,
half of the odds on Sunday,
the other halves of each
set the following week.
Before you could even begin
to visit you first had
to apply for permission to enter.
You had to get your
name on the list.
This could take months and then the
visits, themselves, were odysseys.
You generally set out at about
four or five in the morning,
in half dark of predawn, and drove
straight toward the rising sun
in order to get to the prison
by six-thirty a.m. There
we would join the line
of waiting cars sneaking from
the parking lot past a row
of suburban baseball fields
that bordered the prison.
At seven-thirty a.m. the guards with
a parade of Kia's and Hyundai's,
Chevy's and Dodge's
into the parking lot.
And then you would sign in
at a lectern at the front
of a canopied structure with wooden
benches that looked something
like a tent revival meeting.
Hosts of mainly black and brown
women, but white women, too,
and many children and
some men footed
in the shadows under the canopy.
We could take in up to
$30 in quarters or singles
in plastic baggies and we
always took the maximum.
The point of this was to purchase
treats for the inmates from the row
of vending machines
dispensing, as it turned out,
quite disgusting microwaveable
cheeseburgers and burritos along
with mystery meat plates.
It also mattered how you dressed,
you couldn't wear blue denim
because that's what the inmates
wore, you couldn't wear beige
or khaki because that's
what the guards wore,
you couldn't wear tight clothes
or clothes that showed cleavage
or skirts shorter than two inches
above the knee or sleeves shorter
than two inches below the shoulder.
If you were dressed
wrong you weren't let in.
You always took a backup
set of clothes just in case.
If there was a focal point
of the control I suppose it was
the attempt to target desire.
And then Visiting 2.0.
Time for my own confession.
I wrote that last chapter
like an academic, which I am.
The description of visiting
that I gave you wasn't about me,
it was about some disembodied you.
To write that chapter I stepped
into the perspective
of an outside observer.
The luxury afforded to academics
when they travel the world
encountering pain and injustice.
To be an academic is
to acquire an excuse
for not owning the pain you see.
I'll have to try again to describe
what visiting Michael meant to me.
The fact that I told you the story
as an academic already tells
you everything you need to know.
That wound of visiting
Michael in prison goes so deep,
but somehow you wouldn't
write the book.
I found it hard to own
up to one simple fact,
I went to prison, I was in prison.
No, I don't mean that I've been
arrested or convicted of a crime.
I have avoided that because thus far
in life I've had that combination
of goods that the ancient Greek
philosopher Aristotle thought was
necessary for a happy life --
resources, decent character
and luck.
My father and mother gave
me the first two items
in that treasure chest.
The Lord, my God whom I believed in
as a child and then did not believe
in and then became to believe in
again as I emerged from periods
of great pain has given
me the third.
All right, so now you know more
about me than anybody other
than my husband, my
second husband that is.
Our wedding took place barely a
month before Michael's murder.
That photo that was up there
before was from the wedding.
But, no, I was not in prison
as a convict and this is thanks
to my father, my mother and my God.
Even as someone who could come
and go I felt the prison's
mark, it's branding fork.
I felt it in my soul, even
though all I was there was a
day's sojourner.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I think we have 15 minutes roughly,
12 to be precise, for questions.
Thank you.
>> Hi, Dr. Allen, I read the excerpt
of your book in The New Yorker.
It was very, very powerful.
>> Danielle Allen: Thanks.
>> And in that you talk a little bit
about some of the factors that led
to the system of laws that
would lead your cousin
to the harsh sentence that he had.
>> Danielle Allen: Right.
>> So young.
I wonder if in the course of your
research you had the opportunity
to speak with any of the
legislators who were responsible
for that tough penal system and
if any of them are now interested
in changing that or just,
you know, I know the purpose
of your book is not
explicitly advocacy,
but it's kind of the next logical
question is how do we change the
system that has led to Michael
and so many others
being caught up in this?
>> Danielle Allen: So
it's a great question.
And I think I want to say
two things in response to it.
Another feature of
writing the book has been
about confronting the strange
way in which capable people cease
to be capable in relationship
to their own experiences
of tragedy or trauma.
So my family has plenty
of professionals
and accomplished people
in it, and you would think
that we would have jumped right on
it and sort of been on this issue.
And we haven't been, so partly
I have needed to explain that.
But so then to the second point,
so I am working in various ways
on criminal justice reform.
And, in particular, focused on
the issue of mandatory minimums
and trying to roll back from that
regime, and also working on efforts
to switch our approach to illegal
drugs from criminal justice paradigm
to a public health and health
and wellbeing paradigm.
And there's good examples
from Portugal,
other ways in which you can use
a combination of legalization
and decriminalization to really
change not just the profile
of drug use but also the ways
in which young people encounter
the criminal justice system.
But with regard to your point about
people change their minds or views,
I mean California is changing,
California just legalized marijuana.
They had a measure just
a couple of years ago
where they reduced the severity of
the three strikes you're out law.
And then the other thing that is a
note of hope is this is, in fact,
a bipartisan view, the notion
that we've gone way too far
with the severity of our
criminal justice system, in fact,
unites people across party lines.
So I haven't spoken to any of
the people who put the laws
through in the early '90s that did
so much damage, but
there is a change.
>> Thank you.
>> I want to thank you
for writing this book.
I've read part of it and
it's intensely moving
and I want to thank you.
I have a question, this may
be just a tiny bit academic,
which is I'm fascinated by
this idea of the parastate
that you have in this book.
And I've been thinking about some
ideas that come out of some things
that have been discussed recently,
particularly there was a two-part
series on one of the cable networks
about the drug wars,
and it pushed this idea
that there has been throughout
this period there's been high level
collusion literally between
the intelligence community
and the drug barons and so forth.
And that there's something, it's not
just the parastate versus the state,
that there's ties there ...
>> Danielle Allen: Right.
>> ... that maybe helped to
enmesh people like your cousin.
>> Danielle Allen: Right.
>> And I'm wondering does this
enter into your thinking, at all,
and in what way possibly?
>> Danielle Allen: So that's a
big and complicated question.
So I should first probably just
define the parastate concept
for folks who haven't encountered
it yet in my essay or in the book.
So basically the argument
of the book is that over --
the end, in the end
there is an argument
because I don't not make arguments.
But that over the course
of the '80s and '90s
because of the way this
country fought the war
on drugs there was increasing
intensification of sort of state
like development of the criminal
organizations trafficking
in narcotics, by which I mean
foreign cartels for the most part,
and the ways in which they
control their distribution system
in the US constitutes the kind
of competitive state
system to US states.
That's what the parastate idea is.
And the question of the
role of US intelligence
in all this has come up, so even I
think it's the Department of Justice
in the 1980s was obliged to
do an investigation of whether
or not the CIA had facilitated
exchanges of weapons for drugs
as part of the sort of contra
related stuff in Central America.
And they decided in the end
that there had not been
intentional collusion,
but that there had been
overlapping forms of affiliation.
And so it is certainly the case
that like the single biggest hole
in our foreign policy conversation
in this country is
Central and South America.
And what the war on drugs
has done to those regions,
the degree of instability that
they experience is deeply connected
to how this country has
fought the war on drugs.
And it's worth just remembering
who knows how much
Americans spend every year
on illegal drugs, anybody know?
A hundred billion dollars
a year for each
of the last, for the last decade.
It's like we're just pretending
it's not there and that's foolish.
Oh, I'm sorry, go back to this
mike and I'll be back over here.
Thank you.
>> I appreciate your book and
I look forward to reading it,
as I've only read excerpts
at this point,
and I appreciate your
presentation today.
But you spoke about the
prosecutorial discretion,
but what about once
a person is in prison
and the inhumanity,
the lack of dignity?
And there are people who think that
people go to prison for punishment,
yes, but it appears that
they go as punishment.
I mean they're punished even
worse when they're there
and they're treated in such an
inhumane way, and I say this
because I worked as a law
librarian in the prison and I came
as a person who was a law librarian.
And I was always butting
heads with the administrators
until I finally left after
three years because I refused
to treat people in an inhumane way.
Can you speak to that,
man's inhumanity to man?
Thank you.
>> Danielle Allen: Thank you.
So I mean I think you probably
all know the basic story
that there's sort of three different
ways you can think about punishment.
It's for rehabilitation, it's for
retribution or it's for deterrence.
And this country had an orientation
for its rehabilitation in the '60s
and '70s that gave way and that was
pulled out of the prison system.
And it was replaced, but people
usually say that it was replaced
by a retributive turn, a
sort of vindicative turn.
I think that's actually
wrong, it's the wrong way
of thinking about what happened.
I think it was replaced
by a turn to deterrence.
Now the reason that matters is
because the point of retribution is
like it's the whole
eye for an eye idea,
like there should be
proportionality.
So in Michael's attempted
carjacking the good news
about this terrible incident
is that the only person
who was hurt was Michael.
So his victim got his gun
and shot him through the neck
and he got a sentence of 13 years,
and that in my view
is disproportionate.
So retributive punishment would
have been call it four years,
something like that, all right?
From my point of view.
The point of the deterrent
punishments was
that there was this aggregate
experience of carjackings
that the society was trying to shut
down and so it was that aggregate
that was being targeted
and so particular cases
couldn't be directly addressed.
But so the first instance
we need proportionality back
in the criminal justice
system, but then we also need
to bring rehabilitation back in.
Because as the focus
went to deterrence
in the '90s education got
stripped out of prisons,
and this is to the
point about humanity.
People were not given the
opportunities to develop themselves,
so there weren't college
courses available any longer,
there was not support for Pell
grants for prisoners and things
like that, so beyond the GED they
couldn't continue their education
and that's just one example.
I mean prison is a
very brutal place.
And if you want really kind of
textured sense of that, too,
there's a good book by a guy named
Duane Betts, who also was convicted
of -- in his case I think a
carjacking, an attempted one,
when he was also I think 15.
He's recently graduated
from Yale Law School,
he's now doing a Ph.D.
at Yale Law School.
But he -- I can't remember the
title of his book, but Duane Betts,
B-e-t-t-s, gives a great account
of what his experience was
like as an incarcerated person.
So my book is kind of
like the perspective
of the women visiting, okay?
And Duane's book is like the
perspective of the kid inside.
And then you have Michael's voice
in the middle of this one as some
of the perspective
of the kid inside.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Professor Allen, I'd like
to thank you for all your work.
I'd especially like to thank you for
your work on mandatory sentencing,
which not only messes with
the notion of three branches
of Government but also
challenges the concept
of the faculty of judgment.
>> Danielle Allen: Right.
>> For the judicial sector.
Thank you for that.
I wanted to ask you when
you all visited your cousin
in prison how did you go
there, who went with you,
and what did you all talk about on
the way there and on the way back?
>> Danielle Allen: So I
have two minutes left,
so I'll just read you a little
bit more that will answer
that question for you, okay?
It comes right after the
section I read you where I talked
about my parents and my God.
So, let's see, okay,
I've got two minutes.
Okay, I think I'm going to
do it in two minutes, okay?
Here we go.
So the short answer is --
well, anyway, it's in
here, I'll just read it.
So I said I was there
as a day's sojourner.
What exactly did I feel?
The women were gloriously
flamboyant in their dress.
Not me, I'm a bookworm and more or
less dress like one, a lot of black.
Now and then some bright color,
but for these prison trips I
probably pretty much always wore all
black, black T-shirts, black
linen pants, tennis shoes.
You have to do something
to lift your spirit
up when you go into the prisons.
I didn't do it with clothes,
I did it with conversation.
I understand the show, the color,
the makeup, but I wasn't there
to visit a boyfriend, I was there
to visit an Allen, one proud member
of a proud family come to see
another, both of us trying
to pretend that we
had not been broken.
We talked about ideas,
about books and people,
about freedom and politics.
To explain why I was there in
that prison I could try to say
that Allen's have a fierce bond
and that we stick by our own.
This would be right and
wrong at the same time.
The right part about that story
has to do with our all being sprung
from J.P. Allen, North Floridian
Island fisherman turned Baptist
preacher, patriarchal head
of a sprawling family,
half of it official, half
of it enjoyed in secret.
For this reason J.P.'s progeny
extended to a cousinage that adds
up to an uncountable number.
There's surely not one of us from
either official or the secret branch
who does not have in our should the
sights and sounds of tall, bald,
lean and leonine J.P.,
thundering from a church pulpit
in gorgeous gospel baritone.
He is a battle ax in time of battle,
he's a battle ax in time of battle,
he's a shelter in the time of storm.
We are fighters, we Allen's, and
sometimes we fight with each other.
That's where the idea of Allen's
should stick together breaks down.
The whole tribe is full
of its broken branches,
but for those who haven't fallen
into fights the bond is adamantine.
The difficulty of visiting
the prisons was the pain
that I just described, the fact
that we had been free people,
we knew ourselves as free
people, and we'd been broken.
Not many of my family members
could make those visits, actually.
His mother always went.
I went whenever I was in California,
meaning all summer and
Christmas holidays.
And his sister went sometimes.
His brother was never
able to visit him.
Few other family members
were able to visit him.
People in prison don't
get visits that they need.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.